effing pizza akkad have fulfilled a
dream and castle their small hotel on
the edge of town is often booked out for
weeks every room has a motto connected
to Casa this one is the twelve dancing
princesses as in the Grimm brothers
fairy tale
this one refers to an artwork by Joseph
boys
and this boat is a remnant of the
Documenta the rest of the artwork can be
seen in town sometimes the hotel becomes
a stage itself and hosts events for your
show notes when Australia Tom back when
we were at university my wife and I used
to jokingly argue about where we'd live
later on and my wife always had an
unbeatable argument castle swings that
doesn't just mean it has a lively music
scene but that the art and culture scene
is very well networked and diverse it's
fun living here especially because
Castle is a very green town whether it's
the forested areas around castle or the
lovely parks here in town - parks here
in their stats we go through calls our
Park - Pizza Eckart's first
recommendation the Neue Galilei Museum
it presents art from the 19th century to
the present sleds blankets flashlights
the original of its counterpart in the
hotel the pack is an artwork by Yosef
Boyce created for this room in the
museum
this installation by Mario Matz is
called Izola it was in the 1982
Documenta
one focus of the collection is abstract
painting with few colors
you're not a romantic office depending
on how you feel
you can choose what you want to look at
and there's the great aspect that
Documenta purchases are on view so you
can trace the history of the document to
here and since the building's renovation
the use of light has also been wonderful
kept us here on a totally stretchy it
took six years to renovate in refurbish
the building before the Neue galilee
reopened in 2011
this facade with a grid structure is
typical of the 1950s and an integral
part of castle cityscape it's an
architectural style that's finding
increasing numbers of fans Pizza Eckart
has long been one of them the staircase
in the owl car building is his second
recommendation
the freestanding stairs spiral elegantly
up three stories
it's an example of the lightness of this
architectural style which consciously
made stucco and ornamentation of thing
of the past
I love the 1950s it was a time when at
least in design and architecture free
forms and new colors were in demand when
people were open and that found
expression in architecture in many
lovely buildings in Casso I'm especially
fond of the staircase here in the Iowa
cob
if you want to view it you can take a
guided architectural tour of the town
Pizza Eckart's final recommendation
leads to a popular recreational area on
the edge of town here in the forest
thickets almost hidden is the artist
necropolis
he is informed we're here in a special
part of the Hobbit swabs which is more
than just natural forest or a hiking
trail or art in a public space this here
is a cemetery where artists of document
to standing create their own graves
during their lifetimes
an art project in a cemetery the idea
originated with document to artist Holly
kama once they've been created the
graves are left to themselves they're
meant to return to nature art is
everywhere in castle and time and again
it takes us by surprise
you